Guten Tag.
Ich heiße Mehmet Selle. Ich bin auf dieser Station aus als Standardsstätik.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit eingestanden?
Ja, das ist gut. Hauptsache, ich bekomme bald Hilfe.
Ich habe wirklich tüchtige Bauchschmerzen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen Hilfe, aber Sie als Einpaar nicht so viel Ihren Daten notieren.
Ja, natürlich. Das müssen Sie erst fragen.
Wie heißen Sie das?
Ich heiße Irma Müller.
Könnte Sie bitte Buchstabe wieder?
Ja, der Vorname ist I-L-M-A Irma.
Der Familienname ist Müller.
Ich bin eine Frau.
Frau Müller, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe so heftige Bauchschmerzen.
Das fing gestern Abend an und hatte sich verschlechtert.
Ich habe in der Nacht kaum geschlafen, weil ich ordentliche Bauchschmerzen hatte.
Ich musste mich auch einmal übergeben.
Ich fühle mich wirklich sehr übel.
Ich meine, ich habe auch ein bisschen Temperatur.
Ich fühle mich fieberig, aber ich habe nicht gemessen.
Frau Müller, können Sie aushalten, wie Sie Schmerzen oder soll ich Ihnen eine Medikamente geben?
Nein, ich bin ja schon ein paar Stunden damit unterwegs.
Und so lange wird das jetzt nicht dauern.
Okay, Frau Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 37 Jahre.
37, wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Ich bin 13, 17, 1984.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 m.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich wiege 69 kg.
69 kg.
Okay, Frau Müller, Sie haben gestern Abend angefangen oder aufgetretenen Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, genau.
Wie sind die Schmerzen irgendwohin gewandert?
Ja, tatsächlich.
Das hat in der Mitte vom Bauch angefangen.
Eigentlich um den Bauchnabel rum, dass ich erst dachte, ich habe vielleicht etwas Verkehrtes gegessen.
Dann habe ich aber überlegt, da war auch nichts, was irgendwie auffällig war.
Und jetzt sind die so gewandert nach weiter unten rechts die Schmerzen.
Nein, in den Bauch.
In den rechten Unterbauch.
Okay, haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie gestern Abend ungewöhnlich Nahrung gegessen?
Nein, dann hätte ich mich ja jetzt nicht gewundert.
Nein, ich habe ganz normal gegessen.
Wie fettige oder vielleicht fettige oder vielleicht ist es?
Nicht besonders, nein.
Okay, und Strahlgeschmerzen sind irgendwohin aus Außer gewandert?
Nee, austrahlen tun die eigentlich nicht.
Wie bewerten Sie auf einer Schmerzskala die Schmerzen von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 ja leichter, 10 ja stärkere Schmerzen entspricht?
Ja, die sind schon heftig, die Schmerzen.
Ich würde sagen, so zwischen 6 und 7 sind die bestimmt ja.
Denkst du?
Wie beschreiben Sie Schmerzcharakter, Kohligartik oder Bohrends oder Siehends?
Wie können Sie sagen?
Das ist immer schwer, Schmerzen zu beschreiben.
Bohrend ist vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht.
Und so Kohligartig, so ein bisschen in Wellen kommt es schon und es ist halt immer schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzen sind immer da.
Die sind eigentlich immer da, ja, ja, und werden immer stärker.
Okay, können Sie mir sagen, wie guter Formig Schmerzen haben Sie jetzt, oder?
Nee, gürtelförmig ist das nicht.
Nicht, okay.
Nein, okay.
Frau Müller, haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erwähigung?
Ja, das habe ich ja gesagt.
Ich habe mich einmal übergeben und mir ist wirklich schlecht, ja.
Wie sieht das Erwähigung aus?
Ja, wie das, was ich vorher gegessen habe, einmal ein bisschen angedaut, halt so geldlich mit Stückchen und ja, Unangenehmheit.
Okay, und?
Aber zum Beispiel jetzt nicht blutig oder irgendwie sowas.
Politik, okay.
Haben Sie bemerzt, dass sich Ihre Haut, die Farbe der Haut verwendet?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Zum Beispiel Augenfarbe oder die andere?
Nee, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay, okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Normalerweise ist der gut, aber heute natürlich nicht.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Gewicht verwendet?
Nein, leider habe ich nicht abgenommen, also der ja schön, aber nee, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasalasen oder Stuhlgang?
Nee, ich überhaupt nicht. Nein, da habe ich ja nicht Probleme.
Verstockung, Urfall oder?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Ja.
Frau Müller, ich würde gerne über Ihre vorgeschichte Krankheiten etwas fragig stellen.
Haben Sie etwas chronische Krankheiten, zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Wulstukankrankheiten?
Ja, also ich habe tatsächlich eine Schildrüssenunterfunktion.
Unterfunktion?
Ja, genau.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Ja, seit elf Jahren so etwas in dem Dreh, da hat man das gemerkt.
Und ich nehme halt regelmäßig so Türoxin-Tabletten.
Elteroxin?
Ja.
Elteroxin, wie viel Milga?
Oh, das weiß ich nicht, was da draufsteht.
Der Arzt guckt immer, ob die Werte stimmen und dann sagt er mir, was ich nehmen soll.
Ein Protok.
Okay.
Noch an den Krankheiten.
Und andere Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Ja, wenn ich mal irgendwie Schmerzen habe, so Regelschmerzen oder so, dann nehme ich Pancioprazol ein.
Pancioprazol gegen Schmerzen haben Sie gesagt, aber gegen...
Pancioprazol ist für den Magen, ne?
Ja, ja.
Ja, genau, gegen Magensäure, genau.
Ja, also wenn ich Magensäure habe, nehme ich das, wenn ich so das Gefühl habe, dass ich aufstoßen muss, genau.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch aufstoßen oder Rotbrennen?
Also im Augenblick eigentlich nicht, aber manchmal habe ich das, ja, manchmal sonst habe ich das, ja.
Ja, wir haben gesagt, Fieber...
Aber nicht gemessen?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, ich fühle mich nur so...
Ja, fühlen Sie fieblich und...
Ja, ich fühle mich, ich fühle mich fieblich, ja.
Und haben Sie Schütternefrost oder...
Nicht so schlimm, war es nicht so, habe ich nicht gehabt, aber ich fühle mich heiß und...
Ja, und total schlapp halt.
Okay, Frau Müller, sind Sie schon operiert worden?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich vor fünf Jahren eine Gallen-OP gehabt.
Vor fünf Jahren?
Gallen-Steinen.
Also die Gallenblase wurde entstanden, ne?
Noch andere Operation oder?
Nee, sonst war nichts.
War die Operation Komplikationslos oder?
Da waren nichts an Besonderheiten, nee, das war ganz normal.
Frau Müller, haben Sie Allergie?
Nee, da ist nicht das, ich wüsste, nee, das ist nichts Bekannt.
Unverträgtigkeiten?
Honig, ich kann eigentlich alles vertragen.
Okay, super.
Deswegen wundere ich mich, dass es mir ja so schlecht geht.
Okay, ich würde gerne jetzt über Ihre Levels, Gewinne, Heize, etwas fragstellen.
Rauchen Sie, Frau Müller?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht, zum Glück.
Ja, krinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, hin und wieder trinke ich mein Glas Wein, aber also mal am Wochenende,
wenn Besuch ist bei einem Fest oder so, aber ich würde das jetzt nicht regelmäßig nennen.
Ich nenne ihn nicht.
Okay.
Ich nenne Sie bitte eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie mit Drogenerfahrung?
Mit Drogen?
Nee, da habe ich überhaupt gar keine Erfahrung.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder.
Sind die Kinder gesund?
Ja, ich bin gesund.
Sind Sie gesund?
Okay.
Und wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, natürlich, wir wohnen zusammen, ja.
Wie haben Ihre Eltern noch, Frau Müller?
Ja, meine Eltern leben beide noch.
Mein Vater hatte zwar einen Herzinfarkt, aber hat sich davon ganz gut wieder erholt.
Und meine Mutter ist zum Glück gesund.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Was arbeitet Sie vom Beruf?
Ja, ich bin halbtags arbeitig bei einer Versicherung als Angestellte.
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Oder waren Sie im Ausland?
Nein, ich bin nur, man kann ja zurzeit gar nicht verreißen.
Nein, ich bin nirgendwo gewesen.
Okay.
Sind Sie geimpft?
Ich bin komplett geimpft, ja.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Kopfschmerzen, Frau Müller?
Nein, Kopfschmerzen habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Nehmen Sie Verhütungsmittel?
Ähm, gute Frage.
Ich habe eine Spirale.
Spirale.
Okay.
Ich habe gedacht, das könnte es sein, dass ich schon gesehen habe, aber nicht.
Ach so, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Regelwund?
Ja, die ist natürlich stark wegen der Spirale.
Und die letzte war irgendwie vor drei Wochen.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre, nein, das, das,
Frau Müller, Ihr habt die alle wichtige Fragen gestärzt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Oh, ich habe Ihnen so viel erzählt.
Ich wüsste jetzt gar nicht, was ich Ihnen noch zusätzlich sagen kann.
Ähm, ich glaube, Sie haben jetzt schon einen ganz, ganz guten Überblick.
So, was mit mir ist.
Ich frage mich natürlich jetzt so, was kann das sein, was kann man dagegen tun?
Ja.
Frau Müller, Sie müssen bei uns bleiben.
Jetzt kann ich nichts so viel sagen,
vor der Untersuchung.
Aber wahrscheinlich haben Sie eine,
auch, Panke, Bauchdurchsprecher,
Drücherentschen,
aber wie gesagt, vor der Untersuchung kann ich nichts alles sagen.
Mhm.
Zuerst werde ich Ihnen körperliche Untersuchungen,
dann werde ich Blut abnehmen.
Danach sprechen wir darüber nochmal.
Okay, das ist.
Gegeben wir, dass Sie das noch mal sagen,
Sie haben eine kleine,
dann, dann sprechen wir darüber nochmal.
Okay, da ist es.
Und gegeben, gegeben fast, Ultraschall, auch, ja.
Okay, gut.
Guten Abend.
Mahnut, isch wie Mahnut.
Ja, schön, dass Sie da sind.
Ja, ich habe nicht verstanden.
nochmal.
Ich werde drei Monate wieder...
Zwei davon?
Ja, vielleicht wurde es noch einmal gestört, aber ich denke, diese sechs Fragen, ich habe geschickt.
Ah, okay.
Ja, sieben Fragen, fällt ich denke.
Erst mal können Sie mir beschreiben, wie die Beschwerden aufgetreten sind, haben Sie ehalungsamt oder prözisch begonnen?
Die haben, jetzt muss ich tatsächlich überlegen...
Ja, doch, sie sind schon plötzlich, sie haben plötzlich angefangen und sind aber stärker geworden im Laufe der Zeit.
Hatten Sie so etwas für ihr schon einmal?
Nein, hatte ich noch nicht.
Wie haben Sie sich die Beschwerden mit der Zeit verwendet, haben Sie sich verbeten oder verschlägt?
Verschlägt, das habe ich auch...
Gibt es, gibt es, ich habe es jetzt ausgesprochen, das habe ich nicht gehört.
Ich höre nichts.
Okay.
Ich höre das eine.
Jetzt hören wir uns, ja ich sehe.
Ja, jetzt, ich konnte jetzt nichts weiter hören.
Ja, jetzt höre ich.
Ja, noch einmal gestellt, haben Sie in letzter Zeit bemerkt, dass Sie nie wieder unruhe, Müdigkeit, Konstanzation, Schwachheit oder Leistung verlust haben?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Sind Sie bisher schon bei einem anderen als gewesen?
Nein, nein.
Ich bin direkt hier hergekommen, weil er so akut war.
Und bei Frauen, Genöngerische, eine Nese,
er hat gefragt nach der letzten Regelblutung,
und hat nach Besonderheiten gefragt, und hat gefragt, ob ich verhüte,
und da habe ich behauptet, ich würde die Spirale haben.
Vielen Dank, danke schön.
Herr Stamm, okay.
Ja, könnte sein akut Button, aber akut Abdomen, aber ich bin ja nicht hierher jetzt.
Okay, da.
Hatte sonst jemand eine Idee?
Ja, ich glaube, unsere Kollege hat mich ganz genau hören.
Sie haben Recht und Bauchschmerzen erwähnt, aber ich glaube, er hat mich das ganz genau hören.
Gehört.
Mir welches hast du jetzt gehört?
Ich habe Recht nicht gehört, aber so erst nach Oberbauchschmerzen angefangen,
aufgetreten, dann unten rechts aufgehört.
Ja, akut Appentist, ja, natürlich.
Ja, ich habe nichts gemerkt, ja, danke, Herr Kollege.
Sehr schön, danke.
Aber wir werden jetzt spätestens bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
hätten das gemerkt.
Ja, okay, ja, sollen wir das Arztgespräch dranhängen?
Ja, langsam.
Ja, gut, wir können ja auch noch einen kleinen Moment wahren,
erst mal sich sortieren.
Ich möchte eine Frage stellen.
Gerne.
Haben Sie Abiturlosigkeit?
Ja, jetzt heute ja, aufgrund der Schmerzen, aber normalerweise nicht.
Ja, wegen Appetitist gibt es natürlich Appetitlosigkeit, deswegen habe ich gefragt.
Hm, ja, das hatte ich aber auch vorher tatsächlich erzählt,
aber vielleicht waren noch nicht alle da, sind ja einige später gekommen.
Also, ich habe ja so ein bisschen rumgeklagt und gejammert,
dass es mir schlecht geht.
Und habe unter anderem auch gesagt, dass ich nachts nicht geschlafen habe
und dass ich überhaupt keinen Appetit habe, weil ich diese Bauchschmerzen habe.
Ja, ich habe nichts gefragt.
Ja, das kann ja gut sein.
Was ich tatsächlich, das hat er nicht gefragt
und das habe ich auch nicht erzählt,
dass sie beim Liegen die Schmerzen schlimmer sind,
oder ihre körperliche Behandlung,
und wenn ich mich krümme, wenn ich so zusammengekrummelt liege,
also wenn ich mich bücke sozusagen, dann werden die Schmerzen etwas besser.
Hat er nicht gefragt, dann habe ich auch nicht erzählt tatsächlich, ja.
Aber jetzt, oder?
Ja, fangen wir an.
Okay, gut.
Guten Tag Frau Oberstein.
Ja, so, da.
Ich habe heute eine Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen die Patientin vorstellen.
Ja, gerne.
Die Patientin heißt Irma Müller.
Sie ist 37-Jährige-Patientin.
Sie ist heute wegen gestern Abend nach dem Essen
angefangenen Mittelpauchschmerzen zu uns gekommen.
Und Sie würden Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala bei 6-7 liegen.
Die Schmerzen seien Mittelpauch angefangen.
Dann die Schmerzen in den rechten Bauch gewandert.
Also die Schmerzen hätten am rechten, hätten am Mittelpauch angefangen
und seien dann in den rechten Unterbauch gewandert.
Ja, okay.
Und die Schmerzen seien wellen für mich.
Sie habe gestern einmal erbrechen.
Das sieht geltlich aus.
Sie habe in Appetenz wegen Beschwerden.
Sie fühle sich fibrig, aber sie haben nicht Fiber gemessen.
Sonst Anvorerkrankungen.
Leider sind sie seit 11 Jahren Hypothyroid.
Sie nehmen Ältiroxin, sie wissen nicht, wie das Medikament ist.
Deswegen muss sie das Medikament beim Haushalt erfragt werden.
Manchmal nehmen sie gegen Gastritis, Pantoprosyl einmal pro Tag.
Sie wurden vor 5 Jahren Kolelithiasis operiert.
Sie sind nicht rauchern.
Sie trinken gelegenlich ein Glas Wein am Wochenende oder besonderen Tagen.
Sie sind verheiratet, haben zwei Kinder, die beide gesund sind.
Sie wohnen mit seiner Familie.
Sie arbeiten für die Säherung.
Sie sind in der Familie.
Sie finden sich beim Vater und Mutter gesund.
Sie ist ein sehr kind.
Sie ist unaufwählig.
Sie lässt die Regelbeleuchtung vor 3 Wochen.
Sie haben einen Vitalparameter.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Sie wurden schon gelegen, dass sie mit Galatheas operiert.
Deswegen habe ich nicht Kolelithiasis oder Kulostis gedacht.
Sie haben auch die Vertikulitis und die Diagnose aus dem Fernseherdiagnos.
Am Anfang haben Sie etwas anderes gesagt.
Ich habe auch ein paar Kritik.
Es fällt eine Diagnose aus.
Sie verhüten mit der Spirale?
Ja, könnte sein.
Was haben Sie denn außer der palpatorischen Untersuchung?
Labor.
Ich werde die Wut abnehmen.
Was machen Sie operativ?
Wahrscheinlich ist die Diagnose schon in der palpatorischen Untersuchung.
Ich werde die Wut abnehmen.
Ich werde die chirurgische Konzil veranlassen.
Das machen wir mit dem Darm.
Das ist ungemütlich.
Was für Möglichkeiten der OP haben wir?
Ich weiß nicht, wie wird heute noch ein normaler Blinderm anders als laboroskopisch operiert?
Das ist eine Perforation.
Wir sehen alle gleich aus.
Ich bin gespannt, ob sich die Diagnose bestätigt.
Dann stellen Sie die auf alle Fälle bei den chirurgischen.
Ich denke, alles ist gut.
Ich weiß nicht, ob meine Serie anhält.
Der Anamnese war sehr schön.
Er guckt mich nicht an.
Aber das Gegend ist auch ein bisschen ins Auge.
Du hast ja erst mal die Pankreatie gedacht.
Ich habe es aber nicht zweimal erzählt.
Wahrscheinlich hast du gedacht, so einfach kann es nicht sein.
Es kommen auch Wild- und Wiesen-Patienten in die Klinik.
Das ist die große Masse. Die Exoten sind ja gar nicht so häufig.
Aber die Appendings gibt es auch immer noch.
Ich habe die auch beantwortet.
Hast du selber dein Blinderm noch?
Nein.
Ich habe noch nicht operiert.
Bei mir ist alles operiert, was man operieren kann.
Ich habe noch sehr großzügig operiert.
Ich glaube, du kannst am Montag in die Prüfung gehen.